oh poor lady unique New York news so
full podcast was full podcast with
Phillipe Esparza Rodrigo Torres Yemen
Lisa Esparza here with knowledge Chile
right here sleeping all right Aaron over
there chillin on the Wheels of Steel Pat
our engineer ok upcoming shows March 15
to 18 Cleveland and hilarities come on
down there will be a hilarities for
awesome comedy club we had pizza there
March 23 and 24th Los Angeles at the
Novo downtown LA I think Friday of is
almost sold out so get ticket for
Saturday yeah Friday only has single
tickets available for both shows so
basically they have enough tickets for
podcast listeners walking by themselves
March 30 Austin Texas at Paramount
Theater these tickets are going fast or
hurry up March 31st Atlanta Georgia
take your time if you get there don't be
tickets they're a tractor pull our
chicken I get a word tell them no wanna
do a guest partner show who together
booked me a too much he's over there
show black
that's cool yeah I did that show for
that with that guy from Showtime show a
profit
Fayetteville Arkansas a University of
Carson saw a free show free to students
free to the public
anybody near Arkansas Fayetteville
Arkansas at University of Arkansas or
free show free to students free to the
public
of be April 20 Albuquerque New Mexico at
Ysleta resort that's right I'm coming
back to Albuquerque where it all began
it puts wedding which is joy Coco deers
they're not the same weekend they know
he's going to be there before we are or
after know it's gonna be there we sold
out because the casino also will call
their regulars and stuff to be sad
casinos are great they do so much work
lots more days check out Philippe in
WorldCom's last tour for our shows dates
ticket links oh yeah it's not out here
but I am coming to Utah also bad we have
a new ad go for it but it's for reals we
will try to get this which we were
trying to get this podcast on this
network and now we're doing the ad for
them did you know that what's awful it's
now on Spotify yeah we've been waiting
for this for a while
Spotify is making it easy for you to
stream this podcast and many others like
it on your mobile device
desktop or smart speakers open the app
click on the Browse channel and then
click on the podcast section
you pick what's a fool take us wherever
you want to go thank you
Spotify
[Laughter]
we're on Spotify Spotify man is like the
fastest-growing music place to listening
as fast to it people like Pandora bro
like your mom now there's so many man so
many to compete with have like like
nobody wants to buy music the one I like
listen to it somewhere with commercials
because you have a free version then you
have the paid version on Spotify you got
my phone I wonder if I'm with since we
are on Spotify and then somebody listen
to my voice can they put our snapchat
and find and click and they goes to
what's our full podcast these are the
question that keeps you up they start
matching music and rpm and qualities of
the music like this is acoustic versus
this is you know heavy metal or whatever
so that's how they started they started
teaching this system basically like
artificial intelligence so it was
learning you know it learns your
preferences it learns what other songs
are out there that sounds kind of like
this that matched the timing and all
that stuff I don't know it started with
this project called the genome project
and they were basically breaking
starting to yeah starting to process the
the technology behind things like you
know sound town or what's the other one
Shazam you know exactly when you can
hear something they can match it to
the same technical file somewhere in
their data bank would you have that [ __ ]
on your snapchat now Suzanne
yes snapchat will do it too it's built
into recognition I used to work when I
was in grad school I worked for one
semester with a professor who did
linguistics you're all bad huh no the
cognitive behind-the-scenes stuff in
your brain that goes on when you're
speaking that goes on when you're having
conversation things like code-switching
when you're speaking Spanglish you know
you switch between languages and other
not just Spanish but other sorts of
business but when you but that's all
part of that that was I was working with
him years ago this was 1997 and he was
working on dragon software he was
working with dragon software for voice
recognition and they were mostly going
to market this to lawyers because they
would eliminate the dictation to having
somebody sitting there and taking
dictation for what you're saying or
doing steno so you can that was how it
all started but it was this dragon
software was the company that sponsored
his research I concur that's crazy
though man that's just eliminating the
whole ad from like typing or a man
whatever a lot of jobs lost the phone
now you know yes your phone [ __ ] you can
even type it in the conversation this
man was having when we were in Hawaii
and I was just there like Mahalo Mahalo
I was trying to break in there you know
these I'm how Lee's gonna talk you right
[ __ ] [ __ ] Holly's right this guy
was talking about his daughter asked
what she pointed that out Phobos or
public phone booth when you put quarters
in and that's her father was that it's
another faster you know to your daughter
outside the hood hood people waiting
kids in door these days
Oh Maggie I can't believe it about where
we landed in Hilo there was a line of
ten public polls together still yeah man
very mad I've seen you go into some of
the older malls mama don't have
mom I don't have no phone no stop bono
publico can you change homeless people
stand without by public for just just
forgiving people change
make money or parking meters already
yeah you tip them right it's funny here
it is much better when I lived in New
York you had to you basically had to tip
this homeless guy to open the door for
you at the ATM yeah over here too man
did they do it a lot over here cuz it
was I think your see Thomas or somebody
had a joke about 7:00 I don't know who
it was
I'll coz or suppose somebody hadn't
talked about out but it was me or
someone else talk about out what the
homeless guys tell you for the said I'll
ever open the door for you tell you walk
over 7-eleven [ __ ] ain't a homeless guy
standing right there by the drive-thru
yo man let me take your order for you
but understand standing in front of an
ATM they only give her 20s dude I ain't
giving you a 20 I have no money when I'm
coming in I'm leaving with 20s you're
not getting one of these I don't know
where we were but it was cold man and
homely people were pretending to use the
ATM just chilling in there sneaking
after somebody leaves what's up fool
yeah man got my dog Marty Don - bro
Hawaii t-shirt rubber stopper I'm ready
to open it up for somebody bro practice
about ukulele dawg
don't you want stairway to heaven that's
all I do but strum it is hard to keep a
bass solos of our solos
anyone start taking calls we're doing a
call right hello hello some fool hey
what up dog did your first collar bro
you win a hug from Rodrigo you're
waiting for you though
were you from poo yeah I'm from
Victorville California
you made it done primetime now man I
love it hell yeah man you always live in
Victorville yeah well no I used to live
in Whittier but Victorville base knows
over there huh yeah yeah sometimes
sometimes man I actually work over here
in a downtown Riverside Rodrigo did you
two do solos you are big to fill I did a
couple shows out there with cookie
no that wasn't moreno valley' movie no
those cheers Cheers
hey man what you doing over there thank
you bro thank you at least over here -
so what are you doing Riverside dawg
I'm in the real estate industry hey bro
you were like here we go like search out
houses to buy and sell like when
somebody dies no no because we knew the
guy that we work with in Houston you say
that before you the general
at the improv he said he to do that bro
like like just a house a house double
our house that somebody owned for like
20 years ago
I will eat our grandma she will die and
they're like the houses all paid up you
know and I was left to the kids so
therefore but that should be a reality
show bro yo ply kids against you go find
out which other of the kids is the one
in charge and that's the one who makes a
deal with you know and not make the
mortgage payments and then just pocket
the money you know six seven eight
months later when the bank's come
calling the guys already gone with the
cash you know made a little profit in
the by self everliving is that a movie
in the middle of night yeah sake see if
I can take care about that I Matamoros
but it was crazy man like sometimes like
the people the parent died and let the
parent was the one that was making other
bills may making other payments paying
the taxes on the house then the kids
come in bro and didn't have enough money
to make payments and we trying to keep
up they lose the house he goes man it's
sad watch you know what the at the
bidding auction at one day when they get
our bid right away yeah for sure man doc
well you know cutthroat business done
funny money putting oh yeah man we have
a three-bedroom home right here or that
lays only two bedrooms yeah put a
curtain up what they call you fool how's
the real estate before we hang up what
the asking price for a good house in
Hesperia probably like like a 3-bedroom
2bath we're talking a good hole right in
a deep was grass is green the green were
smokin man yeah but uh but they're still
like the
to bring more businesses in rather to
his parrot write more hotel room to his
burial a while first Cracker Barrel
California nobody notice when you're
boarding it when you boarded Hesperia
bro they they automatically gave your
kid a brand new meth pipe with their 14
I knew I'd use both thanks for calling
dog hey Thank You Felipe see you later
Rodrigo thanks Lisa
good morning what's up fool you are
second Carter what up right here bro you
know right here of the stuffy nose you
know jig over here with a stuffy jacket
waiting for you yo yo podcast will you
were careful to deposit do they come
back for the job the supplies are you
good what cities are what city though
Sarasota Florida that's where the cup he
we jerking off that I'm afraid for Fort
Myers
oh no that's one Sarasota was that by
dr. bill the South no in between Fort
Myers Beach oh damn we were just there
you come back to Tampa though in the
all I think I just got a Tampa offer I'm
going back to town or borough in October
like September bro we're gonna big smoke
a big city while G will be smoking big
stars
improv we're gonna be the thurzday bro
all right we'll hook you up with take
I'll be there you want to go no I'll get
myself that that's the way you dig your
handi like that you'll handle it then
this will just show up a path of big
disclosure guys you seen hoarders name a
rice cooker next to their bed right and
there's also people that won't even
throw away magazines or newspapers even
though they haven't read them because
they bottom and they're like dude like
three four months old and then they have
a stack for my seven years supposed to
be you know little prayer I guess I was
a hoarder no little dog
what one time to teach Oh get rid of
these that's what you're graphing I'll
take them
and have three boxes full bro never open
hey bro
before you go you like Godfather three I
mean I should brings a lot of light to a
lot of [ __ ] been going on since like the
early 2000 when you started hearing all
these mass killings like makes all sense
what all that [ __ ] was going on at the
time but look here you need to see
Godfather because all these gangsters
model their lives after everybody that
has a crew or had a gangster crew has
moderate after Godfather one and two
yeah you know taking me a lifetime to
finish that movie I don't understand is
that who's who's J's Woodsworth shows up
I'm lost and I don't understand the
unnecessary rape scene in the movie but
you know what bro it was unbelievable
bro what kind of fat cheese that I blow
you for a cupcake bro once upon a time
but I really felt bad it's a good movie
bro but that's a movie that I gotta
watch in a plane on the way to far so
bro somewhere far
17:01 oh did you know that seeing with
James Wood and work with DeNiro when
they're out the beach the shop that I
turn in st. Pete Oh crazy missile
somebody a president sorry about that
movie have diamond yeah he was always
talking about it so I [ __ ] I just
bought the DVD years ago and you know
shits up a while but so you were locked
up with him doing that nickel he did a
dime yeah I'm so lost
well you're my world down let me say
whether what thank you for calling bro
what's what's up fool what up dog you
made it through dog you're caller number
three good morning we're calling for up
dog are you driving the first hour lad I
got to set up cruel eyes out of my car
open a door no other sack of weed right
there really broke my door there's a
[ __ ] there's two started good
stinky grabs and I said hey bro you live
in Santa Cruz yeah that's badass
there's still no store no Starbucks
right no there is I love do we sleep
there was better night there huh
we did not spend the night there no I
got that will tie without walking to the
arcade let's take a seat oh and it
wasn't how did you end up in Santa Cruz
oh yeah let's go to such a clue because
you know it's rasa DITA Krista bonito
yeah okay I get it
that's one of my parents would always
say about a diverse neighborhood if it's
black white Chinese I get it although I
did she know a little they told us to
get a boil to get it with a cheetah
I can't let although never be proud bro
stain that [ __ ] like he has to go to
consider because again where he lived if
you wanted to Chinese food it would be a
mission abroad to go [ __ ] fight
Chinese food right and he wanted your
brother to work in a Chinese restaurant
so he could make Tenney's food at home
come home he wanted to work at a pizza
place so he could make pizza at home
yeah yeah my brother working Falcone I
learned something wow that's what do you
do is that a cruise bro surf no almost
drown whatever words Red Dog
don't you can see you brought so dirty
just walking at wobble you man John's
looked a lot of people are fun I
understand man like you know like a baby
I'm gonna feel the water anymore but
they're boys it could be dangerous you
can be passed a great room
the water could take you out into the
ocean but you never come back is that
what you're afraid of
I guess our it where did that big copper
oh you're afraid of the ocean
when you're way when you're afraid of
the ocean Easter but we have a job or
you teach what he did Oh your mother a
do what that me and Edward got so high
we're about array we're promoting my
movie I'm not like that oh boy we're
Edward watching a fire it was a while by
the way he performing at the Planet
Hollywood
he will he wanted a fine cannery
like tuna like cannery sardines anything
with fish inside it is time on the ring
not anymore
what's over that it's gone bro though
the ho cattery business God but now some
hipster brought him some sardines and he
put it on but he's dressed like a guy
that was cutting fish all day but he's
all clean Yeah right before about a ray
Brewer pledge every day the word for
ocean of fear of the ocean is
philosopher via your boat you're up that
last phobia bro yeah did you like the
show hell yeah bro I used to perform
their elaborate Pajaro watsonville all
those parts
thank for call you bro man stay up
overnight in Monterrey man you live in a
you work in a beautiful city
stay dry bro hell yeah man yeah what is
he tourists all day huh yeah amen
what your mother a right there's a hotel
room they had like a catwalk you know
you can see you can stand there and look
at the ocean and then it goes to the
rooms or hotel room is that well hotel
I'm not sure cuz I travel by wandering
yeah some honoré i drab of that hotel
one time and then travel at the ocean
was coming at me and it's a it's a real
nice old hotel if party is right on the
water failed oh yeah well day for call
you back alright thanks yeah babe
alright these collars need to step it up
with something to talk about next caller
babysitters Rex Rex Tillerson he's a guy
freaking thirsty what's up fool what's
up fool hello hello
okay bye hello
hello hello what up what up bro what's
up fool you made it now your color
number five I feel like I was trying to
call the present around you got three
big dog I'm here native I was grazing a
little village was of wool village and
Boyle Heights right
hell yeah what's your name my name is
dr. what so Joe so bad you don't believe
this [ __ ] but our last week two weeks
ago when I was in Hilo Hawaii so fool
like you know it was show man I get
Hawaii bro like not even Honolulu like
the Big Island they're like less people
in this town so food the middle aisle
yelled out it was so full at least Oh
village in the house some crazy ass
cholo I know bro that this cholo should
have been like he shouldn't even be
alive but he but father Greg helped him
to lead over there bro living with
amongst Hawaiians and tongue kids and
they all talk like him it's funny man
when you're from the hood especially
you're from LA south-central when you
show to a new town it's like you're
you're like you representing LA bro you
like NASA you're allowed to your extra
allow your boisterous kind of let the
same thing happen to Joe Diaz when he
landed in Boulder no small sleepy town
this guy's full of energy they love him
Reagan gravitated with him and man
that's how this cholo is formally
submitted
I grew up in from Utah side all they
commissioned so pretty much my family
knows who you are they interacted with
you but I really have one question for
you
I'm not gonna sound pretty funny what a
photocopy you for then she like you live
man oh these are please yellow can sweet
know you gotta use the yellow can cuz
it's tangy and a little spicy yeah man
you put out you put up your tortilla
first bro or you wanna get fancier warm
up offers on a pad and leg cut em up and
put them in there with a bomb bro bro
yeah pathos is better than good
yeah man because my brother angel here
to meet you like you know that I blow
it's better to put the sauce at right
when the chips are warming up and then
put the egg and then I cheese and then
at the end throwing more apart or
something you know protection everybody
that has had a pathos ours
chilaquiles loved it
Willie Barcena you know what's the other
sauce it's too watery it's too plain
but I don't know if you I don't know if
you like steaks but if you're making a
steak like a good steak I would make and
into the yellow one so the green one in
there the green one tastes better was a
poor love steak and I better let that
many many years ago or you were to cut
up look if you were to color the
Courtney they're like like fajita strips
you throw in a green one bro yeah you
should just have an episode of making it
munching yeah which one a little village
could be honest which 100 Pablo yeah
yeah public Roberto
brother hardcore area I think the appeal
box is something but it's going to be a
canvas pain I stretch my own town there
and when I was gonna be of the main
building my buddy so village hopefully
bring back the memories oh yeah big so
nightmares your parents grew up there in
the 80s our eighties and nineties yeah
my family came straight from Tijuana
straight to the project yeah but from
there you know they struggled whatnot
then they met father Craig he helped out
my whole family pretty much baptized my
whole family Wow so you let that father
grape episode to her oh yeah whatever I
did like to was the one of mess counts
he's like actually one of my childhood
friends
that's time dad part of me yeah Easter
Easter the river is gonna be doing like
10 minutes at the beginning of each show
at the LA shows yes oh yeah oh yeah we
have also bad Jay Lamont who's also
exciting yeah he's a comic but he does
like sound effects and voices and well
thanks for calling I know you just
flushed the toilet hey bro you were good
I see the athletic department oh yeah do
the doing for free
yeah actually like pounds pounds of
different types of sake and whatnot
gonna get lucky they'll get they'll get
like some people revisor like two pounds
Wow
yeah trading the people the scholarship
they're for golf do they eat free too
yeah no why would they differently no
because you know like for bus
has the money yah-hoo UT has the least a
lot of money for college boards in what
what's board has the least amount of
money in USC but women's women's soccer
is actually has like one of the best
fight like records here and they show
like like a nice phone respect to them
I'm not realistic like they want
national championships like back-to-back
and whatnot but they don't show that you
know the recognition that happens with
the professional soccer too because
women's professional soccer actually
does really well do better than men the
World Cup they do in the Olympics we
need to watch that Billie Jean King
movie it was a really good movie called
battle of the sexes actually get paid
the same you know I know that's what's
like the messed up part too you know
yeah I mean it makes sense for like the
WNBA to pay less because they don't have
the same amount of fans you know
supporting financially but soccer that
it's more equal and or you know the
women surpassed and it makes no sense
yeah but I don't think you know Thank
You Felipe thank you no thank you
everyone
you guys you guys are really good people
was you guys motivate me because I know
that we do motivate you guys thank you
bro we're now we're gonna let you go out
with of Joey COGO dear bro have a good
day bro good steak for those play that's
right [ __ ] was so cool things we
call it in like this man you cut that
fool off II call you guys is like
calling the radioman kitchen hell yeah
bro you want a big-ass log from Rodrigo
with a t-shirt on
I don't know about all that does but
were you calling from I'm calling from
Los Angeles Angeles local what's so
local Oh part of our you doing man game
good broker who were just waiting right
here Chile talking to people I did not
what they do for a living
fight about the live their hobbies how'd
you get into the podcast how'd you get
to the podcast how do I get into it yeah
why you follow along I went to a show
back when I turned 18 and actually my
birthday which my birthday today
my 18 birthday went to a comedy show
improv and you were performing oh yeah
and now it's in there we're like Dan
this guy's funny and we started seeing
them from you and so you saw me at one
of the on a Friday night huh Wow what I
loaded 10 years ago brown jacket there
was one night bro I don't know if you
were there but it was on a Friday night
it was probably one of the craziest
nights you shut that place down to like
a four in the wall yeah man we had a
great time and I think the actress from
MADtv was there and then some guy got
runned over
enough of the improv and then half of
the cholos went outside and it blew like
they're about to do a carjack on a diver
who ran them over and leaving the lady
from MADtv she led the charge was crazy
for that one it was crazy
it was crazy it was crazy bra bra was
crazy
is about crazy bro [ __ ] crazy is
[ __ ] nuts bro
we found a leg was so full you grew up
it earlier well this is your
neighborhood no you have been on a
carton no my mechanic and Pedro lots of
moles over there huh yeah so you're some
more yeah is there like a big Mormon
community in the car cylinder there's so
many Samoans churches out here no not a
lot of Mormons that I don't know really
concede there's not not much of door
knocking not funny we're talking about
religious you know like you know like
we're talking about you know oh I lived
my family we live in a battered diner
and that's why I live in a balun diner
because he couldn't seek help
and we're thinking about who was the
most helpful and most giving religion
and we are agreed because of what you
told me of Mormons they don't sir no one
away huh no Catholics no to Catholic
Charities are hugely popular they're
very helpful to church and they tell
they will give you a plate of food and
then or the gain in a follower
how about Burbank Community Church I
just closed right now be closed if you
have a church why bro I shouldn't be
closed like a realtor I'm giving you
money every week this bin should be open
at 7-eleven God don't sleep money don't
wait but also like what Catholic
churches are supported by the Vatican
all that too or no yeah hey bro what's
your favorite Godfather movie which one
was your favorite Godfather movie one
two or three you know it might sound
funny I only seen the first one
get out of here not all of it you're
gone time wow you guys got homework to
do homework watch one internal and if
you're brave enough watch three because
three sucks
like I just fell in love with Godfather
3 I think the ending the like if you
were finally got it yeah
Godfather 3 kill me now Godfather three
men that scene where it off it all
starts off when when Diana Diane Keaton
him I'll put you know in that room and
he told her then you got married but but
the ending man I was in tears watching
the ending last yesterday and I was
sober but that scene man where when when
when they changed popes that's what
Godfather 3 really takes start going
into full of Fagin you know it's almost
over by them so what it's good but he
realizes they're better he's done man
I'll put you know he's done like Michael
Corleone is done you know like something
that his father didn't like Don Corleone
could've realized he was done it which
is why he and I'm getting killed
no getting kill him inside he got shot
it was he was slipping but um and he
knew all that was going around and there
were any girls here give me the order
just give me the order and then Al
Pacino goes you know you asking for like
you know like you know you're asking for
it didn't tells about you gotta give up
my daughter because he knew they were
dating so he gives up his dog he breaks
up with her he's dating his cousin first
yeah idiot first cousin was the
directors daughter Coppola yes Sofia
Coppola who turned out to be a good
director herself but she cannot act
she cannot act it's painful everything
you like she has this face like she
smelled the [ __ ] or something like that
you know when she gets shot she says sad
like she its embarrass dad so I didn't
know
before also I thought Godfather the
ending the whole thing I was talking
about it but uh I realized that I'm out
of all the Dawn's even even sunny all of
them everyone Benzini all of them
Michael Corleone him of the most
ruthless [ __ ] and he played it off
like he wasn't that the fucked-up part
he did it like straight up like a
gentleman like a gentleman and at the
end of the movie man give me the chills
because he's reminiscing and he starts
to realize that not only did he kill
people he caused the destruction of his
own family like every every loved one if
for every time every time he moved up in
the mafia world he lost a loved one and
that's what he was trying to tell Annie
Garcia I'm Vincent that you're gonna
lose something being to get to where you
are
I really handle this and and so at the
end of the movie right after his
daughter gets killed there's this quiet
scene where just his mouths are open and
then it starts again and when he's
sitting down they start playing um him
dancing was a girl and then when he
finally had a heart attack you know
where he's sitting that we had a heart
attack where that chick Apollonia blew
up oh yeah million times our collar here
in order to be a person like that it
takes you to lose that just the fact
that the story might be interesting and
bring you some closer to the hole yeah
good you don't need no part for a
prequel of a prequel Vincent Corleone
yeah you need him as a you mean in Italy
as a child Oh a Vincent yeah yeah you
need the before The Godfather
like they talked about this war that
happened before the first the second war
that was the whole talk about when Sonny
his balls bro sorry Corleone and when
more green in his bones you need work
more when they were on the street before
they were to Vegas I I never tired you
know I saw that part now I want to go
watch the whole movie bro the hold on
you stop all the 303
it was a battle between old and new man
oh yeah well Joey's eyes now polar 3 is
a whole different movie compart 1 & 2
later it should just be called something
else like the end of the old world
immortal whatever anyway but what's up
for what you think dog we lost you how
sorry that's your homework broke go
watch gone father Tony bro and then go
and then go read a review of our podcast
live what's awful thing the story might
be interesting and brings and wraps it
all up but that doesn't what's up bro
how are you blog fellow years later
lapacho a beanbag I'm just chillin
chillin bro and do a do a bull rip for
us bong rip do something were you at
home
hell yeah bro that's where you throw in
you oh you got the slag going bro that
should make you laugh you could give
yourself a better 30 minutes when you
coming back
Google nothing in that guy laughed and
he don't worry about waiting another
hour
can you play angel baby bro you know
you didn't take a whole ratty bro you
took a rat on that were being we
referable you an exterminator level G go
Portland Portland Oregon
oh poor lad I love Portland man another
play that my move did you go to his
shell tri-cities in January
yeah I did man I just saw you at the
revolution theater a couple weeks ago
what's the weather like over there bro
they're pretty green a couple days ago
how did you end up in a Portland you
were born
[Music]
that's what Richland Pascal in another
city Kennewick shout out to Rory yo bro
yeah Matt can awake oh we're doing a
show in Richland Richland doesn't
doesn't have no marijuana medicinal
herbs well it's not it's legal in the
state of Washington but not in that area
the border right it's an a border of
Richland right remember this
good-looking guy to goes to that we're
looking to convertible he took us to the
smoke shop in the whole time here him
and his wife his wife was blond she was
like five eight ten and he this guy was
six two they were both a shame we're
calling a barbarian Ken doll so Ken
Dahmer he he took her to a smoke shop it
was like 40 I'm only 38 minutes away
right yeah it's pricey wasn't that good
oh you know what yeah
know what like yeah there isn't any like
shops inside this baby but there's a
mouth yeah it was when I was Tyrone
oh yeah it will write offs bro it took
us an hour apart a lighter and again
everything everything in Richmond shuts
down at 8 p.m. bro oh you're right we're
walking around for a lighter for like an
hour
we asked that guy smoking a cigarette
bar your life that's how you know in
Ohio I don't know if it's still this way
but in Ohio about alcohol they have it's
a you have to get your alcohol from a
state store which is nine to five yard
ride a and you can't go to later liquor
store or go to a supermarket I think
what anybody man telling you can't drink
on Sunday and you can treat at noon you
can do part of our socialism thing it's
yes battery by somebody attempt oh you
can't smoke weed - after 421 4:20
somewhere it would be cool if I plug the
local show here on your joy and that
Google oh yeah it's a meteor the word
the boiler yeah you're too mean Iannetta
yeah locally locally yeah locally right
here I'm doing my foot in the door
somehow there you go you go ahead bro no
for steel-toe all right so so yeah if
you're poor lean in this around order
surrounding areas call most and
Hillsboro are you everyone out there
come check up the Holocene tonight it's
got the Trager method show I'm gonna be
on it when I miss Bennett Andrade you
got some other comics locally here Jason
treasure cave mercy but not but so come
check it out it's free as a hollow
spirit starts at 8 o'clock for the
hottest team
don't be doing that jokes over there
don't be doing our jobs over there but
we'll find out no because I saw you on
Last Comic Standing in there nice and
that's all you're special what is it not
not translate this I'm not gonna laugh
at you yeah ever since when I was like
when I heard you thought I was like a
dad to talk to the language that you
know we grew up in and I was like oh and
he's but he's funny yeah hell yeah bro
let me tell you bro when I was enjoying
this podcast we both we I didn't even
know that when he started doing stand-up
comedy he read the same book I read it's
called Jean Perez comedy writing step by
step I think you should get that book
and it'll help you write Joel in better
yeah you read Yeah right
Perret PE r ET comedy writing step by
step and you'll get it on um on you get
it on Kindle you could buy it at the
bookstore all right
it'll help you write bro it's a lot of
homework there but you know if you have
time to dedicate yourself to learning
how to write jokes it'll help you know
that that man thanks for the thanks for
the advice when I really appreciate no
predictor easily go everybody trajectory
so Marcella
yeah see that's art I think that's a
white way of saying your career yeah I
know I like it hell yeah bro
you know what next thing you know bro
you're gonna be living out there on our
[ __ ] Street what was it called Brown
Street Brian stone less tree we're back
with what's over there Portland though
the hope later in a homeless camp or
just a regular hipster white boy
sleeping asleep instead of living in a
sleeping bag bro reading a book in the
middle of street look at my eye I'm I'm
gonna get a tiny house I'm a tiny house
I swipe release me release
about doing that hell no we lived in a
tiny house killed each other no what do
you know buying a bunch of little houses
at random all that yeah yeah I thought
you meant how big are you bill
me I'm 6 foot 4 ok blockbuster name for
your dog do tell you lost yeah but look
now I was going to say that the tidy
house unlucky that is it's a it's a
model called 10th by Coleman I don't
know if you ever heard of that company
I heard of Colbert I schoolers they make
thermoses on the industry that's what
I'm talking about a dozen gotta go eat
let's play it was gonna be like this
easy to get booked for a comedy show
you know we booked a hotel just drive my
house here yeah man
in lateen well bad now it is my tiny
house yeah this shows our shows are the
air of Friday this Friday this Friday so
I don't know they're gonna do a show
tonight but if you have another show
coming up in the future I want to just
mention it now but we're on YouTube
right now so though we're on YouTube for
though here bro so yeah man so say it
again bro Halloween tonight shout-out to
y'all for letting me plug that joint no
problem in the future just just check
out better on the rather poorly page on
and every lovely page element I what you
do but you gotta find yourself another
Latino that's pretty much knows how to
work social media knows how to work on
the internet knows how to do all that
stuff and you Sparky's tell yourself a
podcast bro
and you put up you put a show on there
you go bro you just what you should call
it and we'll talk to you later bro you
have a good time importantly
hey thank you Yemen let's be shut out
two grand Ghana
grand Ghana or dran grand Ghana
gonna drag whatever and every one of
them's good up oh well what's our do an
ad we can do it with the next caller
though he can write we can play along if
he or she hello was a fool oh my god was
uh what's your name what's her name is
Trish who landed what's up think you
were calling from 62 I got tickets to
see you next Saturday
hell yeah VIP but they're bad they're
welcoming it's pretty good seats all
around I'll be louder to say that I
really enjoy your comedy and you're one
of my favorite comics and I'm listening
to your podcast and you know I've seen
your show on Netflix and I just been so
I followed you on Instagram yeah what's
your name on Instagram go find out how
about stalking you I will add you what's
your mission your Instagram name right
now Beetlejuice right bridled
beetlejuice everybody bride of
beetlejuice
first-time caller on the wonderful
podcast Oh grandpa monsters you have
grandpa monster on your page how did you
get it how did you want find out about
our podcast I just cuz I follow you on
Instagram
oh listen to a podcast before no I've
been listening to it for like two days
straight though all right Thank You Man
my wife and I we have another podcast
called enchilada casserole yeah I just
we've taken a long break from that
recently yeah these are very busy and
man the video has what we call yeah man
yeah
it's like our like our step brothers for
the word selfie there's getting out -
man I'm not really into the internet and
stuff so I'm like barely getting into
the internet also man you know white
will make it easier for you now and
we're on the what's awful podcast it's
not a Spotify now okay I'll check it out
all right don't go nowhere man we did do
a little ad commercial and you're gonna
be in it
oh well stop fool me on these you want
to look good in your underwear and be
comfortable right don't sacrifice style
or comfort just checkout me undies the
perfect balance of comfortable fit every
month they have new prints and they live
right right at your door me undies uses
a special soft fiber from beechwood
trees that's super soft and cooling
unless you have you doing stand-up
comedy or security guard me unleash has
lots of prints and designs - how to
choose from with 100% satisfaction
guarantee
love the undies or your money back me on
these has an exclusive offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you purchase any me on these you
get 20% off and free shipping me undies
is so sure your love their underwear
they offer 100% satisfaction guaranteed
that's right man even if you share them
don't think I'm back if you don't if you
don't if you don't love your first pair
you get a full refund
yeah man didn't even care grow like if
you don't like it those end up just in
the back bro dirty or not those thing
your money back this is a little brainer
get 20% off a pair of the most
comfortable online you'll ever put on to
get you 20% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go Tommy undies comm slash fool that's
me undies dot coms last fool let me tell
you man
I wear these underwear and I'm
comfortable like the plank um there's no
there's no
there's no like Titan is gonna be in the
middle you know like like you know like
sometimes man like you know like your
your tent your balls move to the side on
Hanes right here money like the
aggressive like separate package in a
separate package like you can just toss
in a little basketball the owner it
comes with a ball basketball and it no
frills like if you take a photo of your
wedding underwear it looks like you're
holding a softball in the middle but it
feels better separating everything from
your legs and all that right yeah I
wouldn't know I breathe better
perfect for a guy that wants a kick in
the balls and I breathe better brought a
crying laughing yeah yeah no sweat a lot
like I would on the t-shirts like the
sweat that I get now it not to sweat
from my ass it does with for my back
coming into my hands under my t-shirt
you wear like an undershirt plus the
shirt you slept in and hung around in
all day plus the shirt you're gonna wear
in the show with me first under word
that could take off and look at it and
not throw away it sound comfortable I
think that's a good idea
you know so you think what you think
they should have me Penny's most of
treasure didn't have me Patti women one
of the big Bush right we got treasure
here just eagerly wait so you go there
with your husband your boyfriend no I
don't have a husband anymore
Oh what happened because I got through
the arlov Oh dedication in like 2012 Oh
after me and my husband separated like
right after and I left a long us a
message about I was celebrating 10 years
hopefully we have another 10 years and
then we broke up
Wow right after the dedication how
lovely to get into our LeBeau but it was
calling and calling and calling and I
finally got through and then they put me
on the air but it's like you leave a
message and then 10 minutes later you
hear yourself on the air Wow what did
you say do you ever would you say though
would you think I just said that
well I wanted to see something for my
son but my mom said that's more for like
a husband kind of things so I said oh I
just want to wish you know my husband
thank you for 10 years and hopefully we
have another 10 years together and but
that was a long time ago we separated
like a long time ago did you just
separate it right after the call in so
you put me on blast after 10 years
enough about him let's get back to you
wow man that's the Wow I'm glad you're
wrong I'm read that more women are
getting into our podcast because yeah
they could love listen to our podcast
where I work - man yeah man which would
be the Howard Stern of their day well
thank you very much for calling Trish I
will see you at the show and I'm hanging
out by the merch by Rodrigo and I'm
gonna come out later on maybe like 20
minutes and say hello to people okay
I'll be there at the seven o'clock show
on Saturday all right thank you very
much gonna be a little bit of thank you
well sir bro calling it from Norwalk
what up hello what's up we could marry
me yeah we can hear you we caught it
from five six - from Long Beach this is
about six nine eight mega man what's up
mega-bad everybody hey bro I don't know
what you're doing with your phone but if
you need a radio or anywhere with
magnetics or you're just we're drawing
right now stop all that he compared any
of you what's up everybody is a bigger
man from Long Beach the guy who drew
Rodrigo exactly the way you know sitting
down at the beach okay okay anyway so
this guy back this guy man is the guy
that been hooking up with chicks from
podcast listeners and going to Hueneme
shape craft beer factory building [ __ ]
antagonist in all of those this is mega
man mega man b people mega tank fool
without the yoyo your podcast i need to
[ __ ] edible of death
what sofa how you bedro gummy bears and
I was tripping balls that night heard he
puke dog hey bro so you went to the how
was the hardest time again so bro oh
that like we do we went there it was
crazy crazy buddy my teeth were they
like better than the other one
extravaganza
I didn't go to the Christmas plan I went
to heart Stravaganza but it started
around like about 9:00 but I left early
because of those those edible gummy
bears I think I had about like six or
seven edibles my god oh my god was it
like balloons triple zero donkey it was
good
what what happened there any strippers
there or anything crazy sexual he missed
out on I got like a big like a fat guy
like a Cupid guy I think I know that
opposed man I think I saw a [ __ ]
Gumby and pokey
Malindi without their what's up fool
master what would you do it today man
look more outfits got a fork yeah I just
got off work in later on I'm gonna go
see Marty maretto he's gonna be at the
Brea improv so I'm gonna go check them
out him and her Oh badass yeah yeah
YouTube right now if you're on YouTube
good man so you know you're out there
you're gonna come with me so it's all me
and my girl we're all from Wilmington
area back in the day and we're just
gonna represent a hooker in Martine you
know on his on his comedy show tonight
everybody listening right now man
YouTube you wanna go check out my team
or a No and hooter gonna know for now yo
yo yo podcast go check out much today at
the Brea improv and eight o'clock p.m.
if you listen to this on Friday don't
even live with what I'm saying right now
see man another show don't show up man
and I keep stupid like I tell my team
whatever be here whoo
he was here yesterday pool what's up
cool so what so you listen to me for the
first time on Jorge Perez happen you
listen to be enough for the first time
on Jorge Perez stories huh yeah I was a
little nervous and stuff but now that
you know hearing you guys in the podcast
here in the air I mean I I mean is this
I won't be like all like super shy I
think though so we kind of like made it
more easy relaxed and that I think
that's when I start I started opening up
more and and that's what me like oh my
god the [ __ ] Craigslist booty killer
you know yeah
it has this whole person out for sona a
mega mom what do you do for a living dog
well was so fool we're gonna rustle
Romania right here market I work late
night seriously you're into marketing
how you're the guy who gets although you
get other shopping come on Sabri oh man
yeah I mostly midnight from like 12:00
a.m. to maybe like 10 10 o'clock in the
morning so because he's always getting
awkward I'm drinking in the morning like
he's having dinner and drinks in the
morning he's trying to get you a fire
right now no no he gets off work like he
goes his nights are switched in his
daytime after work in the morning is his
night you know you don't know me I'm a
horrible Koski man he was all night and
takes all morning causing wakes up you
look to work call him bro that's what
happened
thanks for calling Doug alright yeah we
got Doug love trying to call it so much
withdrawing for eating edibles bro
what's up fool calling in from 74 oh
hello hello hello hello hey what's so
cool oh hey Holly from Ohio huh man yeah
I'm in Ohio what city are you in what's
left what city in Ohio Jamesville my
wife hired me to call and say what's up
fools listen I Drive a cab I'm in my car
all day I call radio stations to win
tickets all the time I have never called
a number so many times in my life I'm
from Ohio - I'm from Dayton Ohio though
it's about a couple hours yeah I go
there I go there sometimes - I Drive
people to doctor's appointment yeah
Wow we're gonna be in Cleveland this
week yeah you're near Cleveland wait why
are you near Cleveland you're not
nuclear
not not that not today I mean today I'm
in Johnstown yesterday I was in st.
Clairsville and the day before that I
was in Athens
what Friday night what's your name sup
misty thank you for calling man so
highlight but listen to our podcast and
thank you for taking us on a ride on
your cab and listen it to us
heck yeah and my wife I she's at home
right now watching she's she's loving
life hi yes
thank you thanks guys uh-huh oh thanks
free thanks for your shoes gonna freak
see I got so many brownie points with my
life with my wife right now oh hello you
each other that we said what's up fool
she's listening thank you so much
what's up ash what uh hey you made it
what's up fool see you guys oh yeah
thank you guys out there make you money
huh yeah that's all I do all day I love
it I'm addicted hell yeah magic use we
drove a cab all day all day club between
12 and 15 hours I'm driving this thing
then you get off the cabin do it this
time huh yeah well I go home man and
Sheila a heck of a cook let me tell you
she started man the food is on point I
don't know what does she make casserole
everything no well last night we had we
had pork chops last night and the
macaroni and cheese green beans oh man
it's something different everyday oh my
my father oh my god
that was two nights ago last night she
made rigatoni and garlic bread oh damn
you guys you go for a walk yeah there
you go lucky man let me tell you what I
do is when I'm in between clients I go
I'm a couponer and I head up all the
stores and head of all sales
Wow so you have a lot of toothpicks yeah
those couponers though they they ruin
the game
for all the normal people doing others
dream they kind of do
you know the story the swords make they
get the money back for the coupon and
they make an extra eight cents on it
and I don't know crazy and I'm not a
paper couponer I'm a digital coupon so I
only get like two accounts worth of
stuff you know what I mean welcome what
the most money you saved in one one
shopping misty like well like a hundred
and something dollars but I also do this
thing called tinny shopping where things
that were supposed to be removed off the
shelves weren't removed and if not and
you find it it's a penny so it's like a
treasure hunt and I'm a doll or general
and I'm really good at it it's called
what is good to know it's called what
penny what penny baby shopping yes you
can look it up on Facebook it's on their
secret bios expired dog food for a
dollar it's not even it's not even food
it's like stuff like I get woosh rags
bath towels well I've gotten concert
ersatz I've gotten headphones for my
kids like it's everything it's not just
food hoarder
because I started from people and and I
got the paper but the problem was I
would end up with like shelves of cereal
and toothpaste and shampoo nothing else
nothing else and like I'd the order is
Old Spice my mom is that Family Dollar
right now China
she's stocking up on accent Old Spice
right now that's funny
Wow yeah and we got a we got a big
family so what she usually just she goes
through her stockpile and that's what we
get for Christmas she just a big basket
you and your wife have kids yeah we have
three boys so so you have your boys
there and she has her boys I have two
boys and she has one wow man that's
beautiful Matthew Brady Bunch
that's a new Brady Bunch they got like a
mixed couple with Brady Bunch
those brave we've been we've been
together five years and it feels like
the Brady Bunch it's it's going real
good was that like two women raising
kids are they okay with it in a town
like that's howling Zanesville oh yeah
well it seems like the the town our
town's a little bit better it's the
smaller towns around us but yeah we
don't have a problem everybody loves us
you know her people love me my people
love her I think one of your kids might
grow to be a comedian which one of my
kids would want to be a comedian I think
one of us could be gonna be like then
you know what they like growing up with
two moms
they both say no at the same time
[Laughter]
already
because your sons are gonna be like the
greatest arguers with other women yeah
but they have the best practice brah oh
[Laughter]
you're starting to be like mind-bending
women Wow
thank you for calling misty and um I'm
happy for you and your wife and I hope
everything works out for you guys thanks
for calling ever be the listener we love
you guys thank you guys all right misty
that's beautiful hot like you know you
don't see that a lot you know like you
see like I'm me at least I know we're a
mixed couple and she had her son and I
have my
but you know you never see like the
female version of it like a black woman
and a white woman together on a Latino
woman I see a lot of my shows
and we know they pou was up though so
you live in with somebody two dogs
waiting for you to check I was waiting
for you to stay block this guy now we
don't block nobody bro listen yes
they're talking about they're talking
about my what's up fool from where I'm
Sonoma County last time last time I
called in you said okay block this fool
and they said what's up
oh it's also Noma also weeb and you
already know my throat what's up bro you
been for the last time all right
are you happy now right good are you
happy with that we have a college show
today and well you know what I just
tuned in because I'm actually at work
right now which I'm not supposed to be
but I mean beyond the format is what I
work at the nuclear power plant please
call them mosquito abatement place I'm
the beat you more school I know
mosquito questions Zika virus yeah no
kidding we work ever by a riverbed with
River back we're better usually we work
at town called catotti just between
Santa Rosa and Petaluma up here in the
North Bay whoo yeah well we had the
fires oh yeah yeah but I just wanted to
call in and see what's what's up with
you guys I show you guys those videos
and whatnot Hawaiian is is the bomb yeah
bro i think imma run away and move there
one day
no way well it away with Lisa Amen what
would he do they're allowed to give
their you going
yeah for your mosquito abatement what
are you doing just sitting traps and
ship warm what do we do they spray him
with skin so do chemicals Wow
well we have actually we have a lab here
and what they do here is they collect
the mosquitoes in the two counties
because it's not just Sonoma but it's
also marine and we call it probably have
a maybe about twenty technicians that go
in day in day out and they collect
samples of oh you know we get we get a
lot of common phone calls from from the
local ask them to come by and you think
army and we just thought we just don't
only do mosquitoes here we also do Rosa
wrote it yeah do you think um there's a
lot of um a lot of testing on mosquitoes
will you live at because of all the
growing of Agriculture you have over
there like wine you guys have oranges
you have strawberries and you grow
marijuana you think that's why there's a
lot of mosquitoes out there no no it's
just no is the reason why there's a lot
of mosquitoes it's because there's a
change in weather I mean I'm no expert
myself we know that because we do have a
folks portion here but from what I just
seen is that the I haven't really I've
only been here for a year no Jenna I'm
not privy to that information
that's might not my level of security
clear my bad state most what they put
call you brought back
we're gonna call you those no problem
thank you bro give a shout-out to the
what's up fool and also - yeah man
podcast will do we learn nothing from
that learn fun your stories good at the
Homer Saracen brother nuclear power
just one of the 210 he's still on e what
what Victor fool
what's up fool who's this how many times
did you call how many know he's called
how many times did you dial today you
[ __ ] so uh so you you uh so when you
call in is it sounds busier one any
other goals to straight busy like every
like maybe call little ring one and then
every xx call it was three five it
happens to me two homes
I gotta get oh damn Wow because we
talking we can hear you good but we hear
that God like are there's also no radar
right behind you Oh his seatbelt light
was blinking
anybody we watch those on YouTube no
because we are live on YouTube in our we
you can only do too much that are so
much slacking off American productivity
I know he said you should do that next
no II did yeah well he came into there
but he didn't go to the skid room cruise
yeah Mary unfriend him yeah man so we're
president do it next year again yeah
man I never realized how control a
lowrider cruising was bro like I thought
that it was just a bunch of people
cruise it but no man they have a
motorcycle crew they have people
blocking streets with a permit it's like
putting them like a funeral ghosts yeah
we wear the motorcycle we went like a we
went like a week before but it wasn't
the dark
seven-card yeah that was where it
started and then they drove through
drove down Whittier right yeah there was
a guy who had a really really old
delivery van who were like oh yes and
there was an even custom it's just
beautiful truck like that Helms truck
kind of you know like a seafoam green
one of those cars bro yes those those
ones and it had a special horn on a no
it was cool it looks like a suburban it
looks like a suburban with no windows it
had a horn Irwin you know why they have
that horn why somebody told me cuz
recently because they're you know those
cars are called bomb 340 so the sirens
like if a bomb was going off yeah they
do sound like what so for right here the
horse or full podcast live right here
with Lisa
Rodrigo Torres Alex did large enough for
say what so for your Instagram now what
else has been cracking Alex remember I
was at Maui driving in West LA
[ __ ] the four or five years ago over it
huh
oh man Lisa hated that [ __ ] bro we're
living apart
Trevor living in Glendale
we will have Lisa left five minutes late
yes yeah it was crazy like two hours to
work yeah it would take when I first
started going out to the west side
because I always worked in Century City
or Santa Monica area so I would but I
always lived on the east side so I was
leaving from Los Feliz or Echo Park and
at first it took me half an hour if I
left at seven o'clock but now but then
after I started working there and all
these people start moving to LA the
traffic got worse every year and then it
was an hour forty-five when I started
ten years ago but then when I quit a few
years ago when I quit working day to day
they you know 9:00 to 5:00 sort of thing
will you turn that off yeah anyway it's
people need to move from Milwaukee with
no car it's gonna get worse watch yeah
we need a better we need to transition
out when I was there we know a bit we're
trained system they could compete with a
1/10 better than no and the 10 well that
goes to national I haven't written that
yeah but if I hadn't know this chain
over there by the west side we used to
work it would take me two hours to me
yeah yeah if you leave us on la trains
that was the Culver City line yeah yeah
it was water that goes right by my house
national it goes up next all right yeah
yeah a bit on that way like like a
bypass and pull on a bike and then like
two Latinos they were kind of arguing
and this big-ass [ __ ] Thor white fool
comes up right behind him and choke that
blew out put them to sleep why it's
hilarious
cuz he was [ __ ] he was cleaning his
bike at people oh let's do that
vigilante
thank you brother calling him bro well
so fool I like that large keep shining
on the show man [ __ ] see you I want
to have Theo on we've asked him a couple
times he just has to schedule it with us
so I might have to go through all things
comedy and like poke him that way make
it that like a [ __ ] cartoon character
like Daffy Duck will be cut off
yeah boy the dog yeah true that he was a
mess and he was a mess up until like
what a year yeah you know memory he had
long hair before that - like what - like
me alright this is the last call right
movie better love you guys all right bro
yeah they already know what's up fool
that's it for the college Oh next time
we do a college show man when I do it
even better than this it's gonna be huge
it's gonna be better than this with my
video chat we're gonna see the people's
faces we're gonna clown their teeth it's
gonna be odd so next time we have a
party show and it's just gonna be a
college show it's gonna be a Roderigo
Rose battle between you and the caller
all right boom it can happen later dog
think me something very much look sexy
in the video by the way